excuse me sir do you have a moment to
save the children i'm sorry man i'm i'm
running late and i just don't have time
to chat i understand that i understand
that it's just that every minute another
child dies unnecessarily a child who
could live a fruitful life with the help
of just one small donation yeah i don't
have the time i'm sorry i understand
that it's just all it takes is one
dollar to save a child
all right you know what uh
fine you're right yeah who doesn't want
to help a child
let's save five children tell me
five not so fast just fine
thanks a lot sir
oh my god i have another dollar
i have another dollar sir i have another
dollar
it turns out it wasn't a ghost at all it
was my little sister hiding in the
basement
making the noises the whole time
oh shoot i forgot his juice boxes oh i
will be right back you'll be all right
with zach i think so okay
so
zachary
you know i'm gonna be marrying your
mother
and uh i'm gonna be moving in soon and i
just
i'm so excited to spend more time with
you
you know
i know
that you had a hard time with your
father and
that it spanked you
and you know
i just want you to know
that's not gonna happen with me
okay
and i promise i will never
spank you
oh
okay that's
okay
um
[Music]
i know why you did that
but
i will never spank you because
i know that you still oh
that's
[Applause]
i don't know that there's anything i did
to deserve that oh hey this
[Laughter]
you
okay
i'm gonna be real with you
you can't go hitting people
all right oh oh oh i ain't coming back
for that
fourth one
all right so we done we got that out of
our system cause i know
that this
this isn't you
oh i told you you want that
oh come on
oh
i'm the good guy
i'm
i'm the good guy
man
look
i'm never gonna spank you
i'm not gonna be like your father
i'm gonna be your friend
you need to respect me you understand
you
i will respect you
charles
if you play your role
now listen up
i'm a bad
bad boy charles
i don't need
a friend
so go ahead marry my mommy move in
or as hard as you want
just leave me the
alone
you do that
11 years from now
i'll be out of the house
and we won't have any problems
[Music]
you don't
and i
will
break you
okay charles
how are we doing i love him
hey what's wrong man i was having a
nightmare oh
again
but you want to talk about it i miss
mommy
hey
i know i know it's hey me too me too
pal come here man
[Music]
it's all right hey it's okay it's gonna
be okay
[Music]
i just don't want anything ever happened
to you
happened to me hey
come on man ain't nothing ever gonna
happen to me really
yeah
that's what i said
so yes that i'm nothing never gonna
happen to me you ain't never gonna have
to worry about nothing happen to me
what if what if you got hit by a car or
something
that's
impossible because i will never die
so i can't
die
no matter what you can't die
but i thought all human beings died
that's true that's true that's science
so that's true but i
am lucky because i'm
i'm not a human you are not
i never told you about this no
you know i'll just let it out i'm from a
planet
called
thelonious
the thing is it was being destroyed all
right
that's what happened my
was i was sent down here in in a capsule
to earth by my parents oh like superman
superman yep that is what it is exactly
like
except oh here's the thing about my
version only one superpower immortality
oh
yeah so i'm tired daddy's tired
can you
let's go to sleep okay listen i'm not
gonna live forever right because
because i'm only half alien
oh no
so i'm gonna die
mm-hmm
you you write about yourself ex
but
here it is
this one slit my mind
you
can build with me immortality the
machine
to give you what i got from the remnants
of my spacecraft so yeah wow you're
gonna be immortal
you gonna be immortal daddy
when are we gonna get the remnants
tomorrow tomorrow
gonna get them tomorrow during
work
hey you got anything that looks like
parts of a crash spaceship
dear mom
right this week
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah will you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa
mr t
never make fun of the way a man dresses
way man dresses is his business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress is not to be joked about i'll pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
[Music]
i'm sorry i judge your clothing it's
okay
[Music]
hey scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van i don't know if that's a good
idea timmy oh what are you afraid of
is it because you have a stupid name
like scout hey
whoa
mr t again
never make fun of a person's name your
mama gave you that name or you made it
up for business purposes either way it's
personal
i'll pity the fool to make fun of
another man's name mr t is a cool name
it's a cool name mr t
[Music]
hey scout wanna do some drugs aren't
drugs bad
i don't know
if you're afraid of drugs
we could drink a bunch of alcohol
yum that sounds good
well guess what your hair is stupid
never make fun of another person's hair
hey mr t a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens
it's just like i've been saying
[Music]
shots that you take
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
boldness
your fools
aah
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
more
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is whittaker i have been
babysitting for 20 years i've seen it
all the thing is uh
forest is a unique child everything is
gonna be fine i want you to have a good
time tonight you deserve it
okay um
good luck
thank you
[Applause]
hey there forrest
[Music]
i want milk
you want me to get your bottle buddy i
want milk okay
this is a baba
i want mama's milk
why can't i have mama's milk
it's a simple request
what yeah well uh you can you can't have
mama's milk right now buddy um how about
we play
okay
i want
i want i want to play with my legos
okay yeah okay buddy let's
get your legos done
i wanna i wanna put the smallest lego in
my mouth that's all i'm gonna do no no
you can't you can't do that what
first you tell me i can't have mama's
milk
now
became a smallest lego in my mouth
what a night
this is a bad start
rapid force it's dangerous
let me get this straight you're in
charge of me
in my house all right forest it's time
for bed i guess then
you're gonna sing me a song
what mama always sing me a song before i
go to sleep
are you gonna do that for me
okay okay yeah yes i will
hush little baby don't say a word
keep
keep singing mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird
put my name in there
i like i like it personal
hush baby forest whitaker don't say a
word
mom's gonna buy
you a mockingbird
good babysitter and if that mockingbird
don't sing
[Laughter]
hi
you must be liam
hey buddy how are you feeling today
i'm feeling fine dr gupta
just fine
this is miriam glass and she's from the
make-a-wish foundation
marion glad
how are you feeling today liam
i'm fine marion glass
good well i have some news that might
make you feel a little better huh will
you make a wish foundation make dreams
come true for little boys from little
girls who are very sick just like you
there are no children like me mary in
glass
of course not you're one of a kind but
we're gonna make any dream come true
that you could ever have okay anything
that's right buddy that's right
would you like to play with your
favorite basketball team
about being a superman for a day
i wish
to drown a man
what
to drown a man in the bathtub
to hold him down while the last
breath escapes his body and then bathe
in that water
all the while singing
surely we don't want to hurt other
people now
do we know any anything else flying a
hot air balloon or
meet a celebrity
my new wish
is to lean over the body of a dying man
and put my lips on his
stealing his last breath
liam
no one will get her no
absolutely not i
i don't even know where you i wish
to take all the prosthetic legs in the
hospital
and bind them together
with the dried flesh of the dead
into a
webbed
massive creature
liam
i am so sorry miss klaus
it's all right he he doesn't know what
he's saying i wish to pee in your mouth
what
both of you
mine especially you oh i wish to pee in
both of your mouths
as i stand over you i'll knead a glass
of water in 10 minutes enough you little
dr gupta
no
you're reprehensible
you are evil
you are a devil child
dr gupta he's not a devil child he's
just a child you have no business
working in a pediatric ward what i'm
gonna report you
shame on you
[Music]
shame on you
[Music]
you really upset mary and glad
[Music]
this is insane
you've made me question everything that
i've ever believed about
the essential goodness of the children
wish
granted
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what does it take
to save a child in africa
to save them from the violence
to save them
from becoming a child soldier
[Applause]
what if i told you
that all it took
was just one beard
for the price of one costume beard you
can save a child from becoming another
statistic another warlord's pawn
be safe
[Music]
that's right
just one beard
and for a little more
you can get him a cane
we are here for that children
[Music]
these are all old people we are wasting
our time
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
go go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
call today
we'll put a beard on an african children
[Music]